Captain Skyhawk, Soar Where No Man Has Gone Before.
And welcome to NEStalgia, a chronological exploration of every NES game released in North America.
I'm Mike. And I'm Sean.
That's it for today, but that's okay because we have a topic right off the bat here.
Captain Skyhawk, Soar Where No Man Has Gone Before.
That's the back of the box.
Is that a good claim for a video game when most video games also take place where likely no man has gone before?
I like to think, and I think this is just, you know, how I was seeing things as a kid, like, to any particular video game, all other video games don't really matter.
You know, like, to them, they're the only ones around.
They're the only game in town.
Or at least their marketing department thinks so.
You know what I mean? Like, of course, it would be the place that No Man Has Gone Before.
If you're going to space, no one's gone to space before.
Right. And that's a great claim to make if you work for NASA's recruiting department and you're trying to get, like, you know, kids or college students, like, interested in, yeah, I want to go where No Man's Gone Before.
But in a video game, I mean, like, you know, how many shmups do we play that take place in space?
Like, I feel like I've been here.
But have we been here in this perspective?
Right. And with this particular plane in this particular vector in this particular neck of the woods localized entirely in your bedroom or living room, depending on where you had the console.
Where did you keep your consoles?
Oh, they were in the living room.
I didn't have a TV in my room until I was, like, a teenager.
Interesting. Okay, yeah, because I think we were a basement video game group, people.
Like, our living room was really, it had a TV in it as well, but I guess my dad would have thought, like, that's for him to watch TV?
Yes, yes. Okay, so, hold on.
Early childhood, you know, when we had the Super NES, that was in the living room.
Later childhood, that's when they kicked us down underground.
Right, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Get out of my way.
Exactly. Okay.
In Captain Skyhawk, which is not like an IP, by the way, Captain Skyhawk isn't, like, some cartoon or some recognizable comic book character.
This is just the name of the game.
And Captain Skyhawk is, I guess, like, a person piloting the vehicle.
Who you never see. Yeah, you never see. The name of the plane.
Yeah, you never see this person.
I guess Captain Skyhawk is that guy on the front cover of the box who looks like Randy Quaid from Independence Day saying, like, you know, hello, boys, I'm back.
Like, it's like, it has, like, that same expression.
So, that's what I'm picturing in my head.
Do we think that Independence Day sort of took liberties with IP from whoever designed this game?
Okay, so, think about it, Sean.
The plot for this game is that aliens have invaded Earth.
And, I mean, stop right there.
That is the plot to Independence Day.
So, obviously, they ripped off Captain Skyhawk.
But, it gets a little more interesting, okay?
Aliens have invaded Earth, and they've built four land bases, okay?
Like, if you want to get a kid hooked, you tell them that they've built land bases.
Not, like, that they're probing people.
Not that they plan to, like, disguise themselves as humans.
No, they've built land bases.
And these bases are designed to drain the Earth's energy and feed it to the mothership.
If the mothership obtains enough energy, it will destroy the Earth with a massive laser blast.
And I know we're talking about the plot of the game and everything, but I do have an issue with the way that's worded, because it makes it seem like a video game mechanic that you will see throughout this game.
It's time. Yeah, that is, like, you know, there's an energy meter that, like, you basically need to be keeping track of.
Like, whatever that thing in Mass Effect 3 was that you had to, like, always have in the back.
Readiness? Yeah, like, what's my readiness?
Galactic readiness, yeah.
Yeah, like, you know, I don't want to be able to monitor that stuff, so I'm glad they didn't do that.
But it does sound like that, based on the wording in the plot.
So, you, the player, must destroy the four enemy bases, and then eventually go after the mothership itself.
So, basically, Independence Day.
Yeah. I think this would have been more okay and less of, like, a peeve of, like, well, they're kind of, this sounds like the story was written in the manual, like, completely separated from the game itself.
But I think it would be less of a peeve if there was, like, if there was a little bit of banter between these missions.
Because, like, it's not just go destroy the base, come back, refuel, go destroy the base, come back, refuel.
Like, there's other stuff that you're doing, like picking up scientists and, like, resupplying other stuff on the, you know, on Earth.
And if there was just, like, some characters that, like, there's a reason that this specific guy got kidnapped, I think it would make more sense.
And then this whole, like, race against time, while it might not be mechanically important, would be, like, part of the story, at least.
Yeah, and I think it does need just a little bit of Metal Gear-style cutscenes.
Exactly, yeah. You know, or just, like, just some extra world building here, because you do get different scenarios in the game, and the objectives are read out on screen.
But otherwise, you know, I don't know where we are on the Earth.
You know, like, occasionally you'll see, like, a sphinx in the desert, and it's like, all right, they just don't have those everywhere, guys.
Like, you know, like, those were specifically placed.
The great, specifically placed.
By the aliens.
This is the great gridded plains of Egypt.
You know that area of Egypt where everything's sort of gridded?
Yes, absolutely. I think that's true.
Well, actually, that's what it looks like from far enough away.
You know, like, how, like, when you fly over rural America, it does look like, wow, so we just, like, marked off all the territory in squares, but really that's just how farming works?
I did. Anyway.
It did take me a while to know that. Yeah, go ahead.
Say, it is not really a shmup.
I don't want people to think that this game is a shmup like Gradius or any kind of horizontal or vertical shmup.
This is more like a isometric shooter game and then, like, suddenly becomes a Top Gun style fighter shooter game, you know, for specific scenarios.
So, to focus just on the isometric one, it's top down, but again, isometric, so you're kind of like at that 45 degree angle.
Everything, as Sean hinted at, is, like, polygon-ish, or at least it has the implication of some 3D effect.
So, there is a altitude matters in a game where you're controlling a ship.
And sometimes we've seen an altitude radar for games that take place in space, and it really doesn't really matter for much other than just making sure that you're lined up with the enemy.
But in this game, you actually have to be concerned with lining up and also dodging terrain as you're going through.
So, I think, like, the actual environments themselves add some character, whereas in other non-isometric shmups, it's either just, like, just don't run into other pixels.
Like, other pixels bad.
This is more like, well, you have to think about where you are on the plane.
And I think that's a pretty cool way of handling a shooter.
There's a lot to unpack here.
So, one, I would say that this is a shmup, just with some quirks in how it presents itself and controls.
And, two, the amount of interaction that you're having with the actual landscape.
Like, yes, it does present some interesting decisions to make, but you could also just, like, not make any and just stay as high as you can.
Because otherwise, this game is kind of hard to parse.
I don't know how you felt when you were controlling this thing to start and if maybe that experience changed as you were playing.
But the whole, like, isometricness of this game does kind of, it's, the implementation feels very off when you first start playing it.
Would you agree? Yes, because there's two big issues.
And, you know, I was trying to just be kind to the game and set it up.
But there's two big issues.
And that is the field of view in this isometric thing is very narrow.
So, you're only seeing, like, maybe enough.
You're only registering enough to see, like, maybe two enemies and a specific hallway of your range at a time.
And then the other problem is, so you're not seeing much, but the scroll speed is too fast for what you're able to see.
And so you're just kind of dealing with things quickly or, as Sean's mentioning, just don't deal with them at all.
Like, choose to just fire and take care of things if you can, but mostly just avoid because you don't want to have to, you know, it'd be cool to fly through, like, little caves or little entryways and stuff like that.
But not only do those not exist in this game, but that would just make it harder because it's another thing to keep track of.
Whereas, really, it's just hard enough to keep track of where you, the enemies, and both of your projectiles are at any given time.
Yeah, and I couldn't really tell what changing your altitude actually did for you.
Like, because I just kept pulling up on the D-pad, or I guess pushing down to pull up.
And if I was just using my cannon, like, I could hit anything, whether it was sort of presenting itself as being on the ground or another, like, flying thing.
Like, I was still hitting.
I wasn't too sure about that, but that is definitely true of the bases, which makes it really silly, right?
Yeah. Like, the bases should be the one where, like, it really does matter that you have to be low to the ground to take them on because otherwise...
And, you know, they can hit you, too, so it doesn't really matter.
But otherwise, what's the point of maneuvering?
Other than, of course, the fact that because the game is isometric, it puts on this whole, you know, as we've said on the show before, pseudo-3D aspect to the game.
That makes it all very cool, right?
There is a presentationally cool thing about the way that this ship moves very fluidly and the altitude being convincing.
Like, you can tell whether you're high above the ground or low to it, not just because of the shadow, but also just because of the way that the textures work on screen and everything.
Like, it definitely sells flying a ship better than, you know, better than any of the 2D shmups that we play.
Yeah, I'd give a hard agree there.
Aside from the fact that, like, the only thing that you can really guarantee if you fly low to the ground is that you will probably crash into the ground.
So, you may as well not really interact with that system.
Is the goal ever as a plane to fly low to the ground, though?
You know, it could be cool if you can control it.
But, you know, the way that the arteries of the field flow sometimes, it can be kind of a pain in the ass.
But, going with what you said of, like, how this kind of sells speed and flying better than most games that we've played so far.
I think there's no better illustration of this than, I don't remember, I think this might be, like, the third level and then the sixth level.
Where you actually have another, like, ship.
Not a ship. It's a plane.
This is just, like, a stealth fighter or something.
Another plane that you're sort of dogfighting against that's sort of traveling near the same speed.
And it kind of feels like a chase that you'd see in a movie.
And, like, the fact that you guys are kind of going neck and neck and you're chasing him down.
Like, that was probably, like, the most tense I've felt in, like, a shmup in terms of just, like, that presentational speed.
That was really cool.
Yeah, I think that's the closest video games have gotten to feeling like Top Gun.
Yeah. You know, like, that actually felt...
Right. And speaking of, there is a whole other type of plane combat in this game that plays very much like the dogfighting that we saw in the Top Gun games.
Where, you know, your ship is just kind of always present in the, you know, in the front and center.
You're facing... The camera's facing behind the plane.
And then these other planes kind of fly in and ahead of you in their field of view.
And the only thing I thought was weird about that, before we get into, like, whether that controlled any different than Top Gun,
is that that's not really, like, the goal of other enemy planes.
Like, right?
Like, other enemy planes should be shooting from behind you, too.
And there's no system for that.
You know, they just are always advancing in front of you just to become easy targets.
And, yeah, they shoot backwards, or at least some of them do.
But it just...
It felt like an extra minigame because it was so inconsequential that, like, nobody is technically chasing you.
You're just chasing everybody else.
That, like, why is this happening?
Why is the enemies so dumb?
Yeah. So, I agree that this does feel kind of like an afterthought.
Though I would say that, again, it does look pretty.
And it does feel like a good change of pace compared to, like, the standard game.
But aside from...
So, yeah, planes will approach from behind you and from in front of you.
And aside from some that approach from behind you shooting missiles that are not really easy to dodge, but they're telegraphed well enough that unless you get really unlucky, you're not going to get hit by them.
Yes, they're not really attacking you.
They're just targets. I think it's just, like, sort of getting enough points to interact with the economy of the game and to switch it up a bit.
So, it's not perfect, but it's fun enough.
Yeah, and I think also that's my distinction of why I wouldn't just call this a shmup because it has switching objectives.
Whereas shmups are almost always just get to the end of...
Survive to the end of the stage and kill probably a boss.
This has specific scenarios such as, you mentioned, you know, pick up the scientist, drop supplies into specific areas, drop zones, destroy the enemy planes, whether you're doing the dogfighting part or whether you're chasing them in the isometric parts.
Like, it shifts enough what the goal is that, like, I hear what you're saying, sure, but, like, shmup as a genre versus, like, shmup as a trope might be, like, where this differentiates, right?
Okay, yeah. Like, this doesn't have the tropes.
I'd say that it is a...
It's wearing a lot of the same clothes as a shmup.
Okay. The plane codenamed the F-14 VTS, which is a fictional version of the F-14.
What does the VTS stand for, then?
Like, why not just make it, like, the F-99 or something, then?
Like, you know, go really high, pie-in-the-sky ideas.
The VTS, like, you got any ideas there?
It almost sounds like they're trying to do, like, a VTOL thing because, like, you can't fight a base on the ground unless you can hover, right?
So maybe they're trying to make it...
They didn't know what the actual acronym was, so instead of VTOL, they did VTS, you know?
Yeah, and I'm sure that was covered in the manual as well.
Actually, no, it wasn't. It just says VTS.
It doesn't tell you what the VTS does.
Yeah, that's pretty silly.
That stinks. All right, so, you know, we talked about how the plane controls and everything, and it is weird to call this, like, a plane.
Like, it's not a commercial airliner, but it definitely, like...
Well, would you call, like, a jet fighter a ship?
Right. No, you're right.
But I guess what I mean is, is, like, it's kind of dull-looking because I feel like it has to be based on the, you know, the power of the NES, right?
Like, there's something about the fluid animation and the way this thing...
Like, it's just gray, and it's just a couple different shades to communicate, like, you know, some depth on it.
Otherwise, it's not, like, an impressive-looking ship.
You know, you're right.
But the vibe, especially of this...
I don't even know what we're calling, like, the bonus mode, I guess.
The, you're just flying, there's no isometric stuff going on.
You wouldn't know that you're fighting aliens because it seems like they have the same sort of 1980s-era technology that we have.
So, it at least is keeping things consistent visually.
Yes, you're right. In fact, Sean, I made note of that as well, that there is only supernatural things going on otherwise.
Like, there's no alien notes.
There's just, okay, they made the pyramids able to shoot fireballs.
The Sphinx are able to fight back now.
Like, is that something...
Were those always aliens?
Maybe. Or do they control those?
Like, yeah, that's what...
Actually, see, that's what I'm talking about. Going back to that idea of, like, they placed the Sphinxes.
Like, this is, like, that War of the Worlds type stuff where, like, they were always underground and then...
Buried there. Yeah, but just the machines were buried there and now the aliens have come back.
I would have appreciated more of that.
Instead, what we're getting feels like, and this is a rare game, we're getting, like, some recycled graphics from other rare games.
This is a rare game?
Yeah, it's a rare game, believe it or not.
Interesting. Milton Bradley wants you to think that they made this game because it says Concept by Milton Bradley.
And, you know, I don't have a developer diary here, so who knows how much was shared.
But usually when you're the publisher, that just means that you, you know, you put forward the costs and the developer actually made everything that the game had to offer.
So, you know, take it for what you will.
But, yeah, I'm having a tough time buying into anything that the game is putting down.
But I'm also having enough fun just controlling the F-14 and completing the objectives.
Like, even the, what was really hard in Top Gun, landing the plane on the carrier, they have a similar thing here where you have to dock the F-14 into a space station.
And, thankfully, they don't make it like, okay, but if you crash the plane, it's game over.
There's no time limit.
You can just sort of fiddle it in there.
Yeah. But, again, it's just like, it's another thing that I'm just like, oh, wow, another change.
You know, like, not that the whole game always surprises you or anything.
That would have been welcomed, of course.
But it's not just like, all right, another shmup clone where all I'm doing is just, the hook is that it's isometric.
Like, this game went well and beyond just a new graphics approach.
Yeah, absolutely.
And, like, just that thing about surprises that you said.
Like, they actually do keep doing that because, you know, you get into that flow.
You get into that rhythm of, like, okay, I'm going to do something in ISO space.
Then I'm going to do something in fly forward space.
Then I'm going to dock my plane.
And you're just going to keep doing that.
I'm going to buy some more missiles.
I'm going to buy some more bombs.
And then, finally, after one of the last levels, you think you're just going back to the space station to dock.
And now you've basically got the Omega to your Alpha, like another space station.
But now you've got to blow it up.
And whether or not it's a satisfying end of the game after you blow it up is kind of beside the point.
But the fact that, like, you kind of thought it was going to go this way.
And then you're like, oh, it's another, like, boss.
That was pretty cool.
I like that. But how interesting are the other objectives of the game?
Like, we were talking about picking up the scientist or dropping the supplies.
It remains to be seen.
Or at least we haven't commented yet on whether those things are actually fun or if they just provide something other than shoot all the enemies.
With the scientist one, it's really just a re-skinned boss, which has, like, a little epilogue, if you want to call it that.
Because it's still like, oh, blow up these four things, and then you beat the boss.
But now, blow up these four things, and then go land, and then pick up this little pixel dude.
Whereas with the resupply missions, you kind of just, the level will end once you sort of complete it in the field.
There's no boss.
And it's really just like, can you time it right to get everything done and get the level over quickly?
So I wouldn't say that the different objectives in the ISO space are really all that interesting.
It's just at least it's not the same thing over and over.
You get at least some visual changing things up.
Between stages, when you're shooting down those enemy planes in the Top Gun-style dogfighting,
those are rewarded with points, which basically points translate into money in this economy
to purchase weapons and ammo, new weapons and ammo, I should add.
Like, better ammo than just the unlimited firepower that you have.
You can never run out of ammo entirely, but you can buy better ammunition.
Truly a capitalist society that we live in, where Earth is being threatened by aliens,
and we're still the only people who are, you know, like, we're the only defense left,
and we still have to pay for the survival.
So maybe it was all priced in.
Maybe the alien invasions are already priced into the stock market.
The invasion is priced in.
I like that. It might be, because they feel comfortable charging us.
So maybe actually all the, maybe we're buying from the aliens, for all we know.
I get it from a systems thing.
They should have just, like, they should have rewarded you with alien tech
for blowing up the aliens, right?
Like, that would have, obviously they would have to also look like alien ships,
to Sean's earlier point, that, like, it doesn't feel like you're even fighting aliens.
But I do think that this is a missed opportunity to be like,
Earth's all in it together, except for these guys who make the ammunition.
They don't care if we live or die, because I guess they'll have the ammunition.
I guess, like, if you can head Canada away to just, like, oh, we're going to,
I'm just going to look at this as we picked up enough supplies
to then convert it into missiles and bombs,
and you're not being charged to resupply your own ship.
Because, like, they're called credits,
and I know that that is 100% just, you know, money,
but it's abstracted enough away that you can sort of,
maybe your CO isn't really trying to rip you off.
Yeah, it's like the, that's this universe's version of the MCU Tesseract stuff
that just constantly just keeps being like,
yep, we have more of this, not Tesseract,
but the Kree stuff from the first Avengers film
just continually just keeps showing up to be like,
yep, we use this tech to make new weapons that created new supervillains.
Ah, yes. You know, just always explaining it away.
Like, yeah, remember that stuff from the first,
it's like, yeah, we blew up those aliens and changed it into this stuff.
So you have your regular cannon, you have,
I'll give them the cool names,
the Phoenix Air Intercept missiles,
the Maverick air-to-ground missiles,
and the Hawk bombs.
And you can buy these,
and they do come in limited supply,
and they do also have fluctuating cost,
not between levels,
but just like, they don't all cost the same.
So the missiles, then the intercept missiles,
then the air-to-ground missiles,
and the Hawk bombs all have,
you know, slightly scaling up cost.
And yeah, because one of them,
when you're upgrading, when you're purchasing something for the cannon,
you're not buying ammo for the cannon,
you are upgrading the cannon.
So you are getting a faster fire rate,
and by the time that thing's fully upgraded,
you can just hold the button down,
instead of, like, mashing it.
And I thought that was cool,
that there was both, like,
long-term and short-term purchases,
because then you end up having to, like,
you'll have to actually restock your missiles,
and restock your bombs,
but those cannon upgrades stay.
That being said,
I did find it kind of difficult
to use all of these
at, like, on the actual field.
Like, I could, I know that, like,
directional input mattered,
so I was able to get, like,
the sort of spitfire,
like, expanding,
like, projectile,
and I was able to do,
like, the cluster bomb,
it just sort of hits everything out there,
but I don't think I was able to use
the actual, like, missile missile at all.
Yeah, it's funny,
because it's not directional,
even though it feels like it,
because there are other things in the game
that are directional. You can barrel roll in this game,
you can do a barrel roll.
You can, with the weapons, though,
it is about how it's pressed.
So, for instance, the air-to-ground missiles,
the manual describes it as just
lightly tapping the B button,
instead of a hard press.
It really felt like I was,
I was, okay, that makes sense.
No, yeah, you believed it,
so it became what it was,
but, like, the bombs,
you have to press the,
you have to, like, hold and release
the B button, right?
So you have to do, like, a full push up and down
on your, with your thumb,
whereas the air-to-ground missiles
is, like, a quick tap,
and obviously, like,
we know from all platformers
that the NES can recognize the difference,
which in itself is pretty novel,
but we have not really seen
this in many other kinds of games
other than jump functionality, right?
Like, I don't think we've ever seen
how you shoot is based on,
or, like, even just switching
what type of ammo you use
is based on how you press the A and B.
It reminds me,
and maybe this is an X thing,
but did Mega Man have this?
No, Mega Man made it
so that you can,
you switch with the select button,
or the start button.
I think it's the start button.
So when I'm thinking of Mega Man
charging up his piece here.
Oh, you're thinking of a Mega Man game
we haven't played yet.
Oh, okay. The charge beam hasn't been introduced yet.
Damn, okay.
I feel like there was a game where you,
I feel like there was a game
that did charge a shot.
I just can't remember it, but you're...
No, you are right. There are definitely games
we've played with a charge shot.
Maybe even, it's been a while,
but obviously most Metroid games have that.
I'm not sure if the first Metroid game
had that or not,
but yes, definitely there has been games
with a charge shot. Cool, cool.
I have vague memories of things sometimes.
On the sequels and spinoff side,
no sequels for this game made by Rare.
Is that surprising?
Is that rare to see Rare not make a sequel?
It's surprising because I feel like
this game is solid enough to warrant one.
I mean, I imagine the sales
must just not have been there.
Or Milton Bradley holds the IP rights
for just the name.
But I mean, I guess it's kind of surprising.
It's also surprising just
the Captain Skyhawk name, right?
Like, I just,
I think it feels kind of generic
and throwaway.
And that's also what might have surprised
you from thinking like
that this wouldn't be a Rare game,
that they would have had like
established NIP around their various games.
And that Captain Skyhawk just feels like
a game you would get from
Tecmo or Victakai,
not necessarily Rare.
But then again,
like Rare hasn't really been
in Rare form
like from the games that we've played.
They kind of have bounced between
like shovelware
and kind of interesting games,
haven't they? So they don't,
like they're not really,
they're not really known for building,
like world building yet, right?
Yeah, you're right. No, they're just an established name.
It's kind of funny that,
you know, we think of them
for their good games,
of which there are five,
but we have 21 skip-its from Rare.
Yeah. So that's a really bad ratio
and we should probably just stop
talking about them in such high regard
when Konami manages to have
five essential games
and eight play-its
out of 24 total games.
Like that's much more impressive.
Oh, absolutely.
Rare's trash. Yeah, I'm never going to play
Banjo-Kazooie again.
Because it's a trash game.
It's actually not,
it's no Super Mario 64.
I'm just going to say it. Absolutely.
I've never played it,
but I have to take your word for it.
I don't think you've ever played
Super Mario 64 either.
I've played, you know,
the, you know,
the first part. Great.
Yeah, the first part.
That sounds like, that sounds very confident
for somebody who has played
Super Mario 64. They always talk about
the first part.
I did. I played the first part.
I climbed up the tree. No, I know, but that doesn't mean anything.
You know what I mean? I climbed up the tree.
I walk around the castle.
I... Yeah, but you didn't even
enter the castle. That's not the first part.
No, no, no. I walk in the castle.
I jump into one of the paintings
and then I die.
Okay, that tracks.
That sounds, you know what? You actually are more convincing
than the aliens in this game.
Are we sure the aliens
just aren't Russia?
Nintendo, what's going on?
Why? You raised a great point
early on this episode
and I haven't been able to shake that feeling.
One other quick thing
before we get to the Essential Games list
because we're due for it.
But did you feel also,
whether it was the dog fighting
or the isometric,
that things did blow up
easier than in other
shooting games we've had?
And I don't mean that the game itself was easier.
The game is hard because projectiles
are always shooting at you and you have a narrow field
of view and everything. But I was surprised at like,
I don't know if it has
like lock-on technology
or something, but I was doing better here
than I ever was in like Top Gun.
So, okay,
do you mean in either of the categories
or just the isometric?
I mean both. Yeah.
Okay. Like I just feel like
the spread on my projectiles
was taking care
of a lot of enemies.
Yeah, I think once
you've upgraded your cannon,
like, and,
I think once you've
upgraded your cannon, you're doing pretty well
and I think also
there might be
a more generous hitbox
in the isometric stages.
Like I think the,
your projectiles
are kind of coming out of the center
of your mass
instead of out of like
the nose of the plane
because you would just,
I would just be doing these sweeps
and it would basically
take care of the entire
screen in some instances.
Um, so I think that
definitely there,
but I was actually
in the like
more behind camera
sections, like the bonus stages,
the more dogfighting
ones, I guess. Uh,
I, I would have a bit
more trouble there
because your aim
is a bit more finicky.
so I,
I, that one still felt
challenging to get, uh,
regular hits.
Um, but no,
definitely felt easier,
uh, just hitting stuff
on the isometric area.
And we didn't mention this,
but dropping the,
the supply drops
and picking up the scientists,
those are done
to build this neutron cannon
that they're working on.
You're dropping the supplies
to give it to the scientists
and you're freeing the other scientists
that I, I guess have been,
uh, held captive.
So the manual
certainly does a lot
of work here on like what the neutron
cannon is
and that like, you know,
once you've freed all the scientists,
your secret weapon
is complete
and you'll be able
to take on the alien space station,
the mothership, right?
But it doesn't pay off
in game. There's no,
it doesn't feel like
certainly like that,
that's a cool final power.
Um, if you remember
in Terra Cresta,
once you like
collected all the pieces
of your ship and everything,
you actually turned
into a phoenix,
right? And that was really cool
and we said that was one of the
coolest parts
of that game. Uh,
this doesn't necessarily
do a lot of building up
that like, oh, neutron cannons
like online,
time to completely
obliterate this thing
but even graphically,
it just looks
kind of the same.
It looks the same.
You're just going up
to the ship
and now you just, you know,
you pop all the bulbs
and that means
you win and then you poke,
you poke it in the eye
after. You pop all the bulbs,
you poke it in the eye,
game over. Um,
the, the projectiles
you're shooting look exactly the same
as they do with normal fire.
Um, and the fact that
there's so little buildup
it's just sort of giving you updates.
It's just like a status update.
Like, okay, we got half of it done.
Like, oh, it's all done now.
Um, that's why I think
that this needed more,
you know, like story beats.
Like, put some cut scenes
in there like we were talking about.
That, that would have sold it more,
I think. Well,
there's nothing left to sell.
We have to do
the essential games list.
I think,
actually, Rare did something
cool here with an
isometric shooter game.
Uh, they really, just like they did
with, um,
RC Pro-Am
and,
um, they didn't make
Marble Madness, but like,
Marble Madness also pulls it off.
It's fun
when these
pseudo 3D games
actually, like,
still work today
and they don't become,
like, Atari 2600 style
graphical messes
where it's like, yeah, you just have to,
like, use your imagination
to understand
what's going on. It's like, it's very clearly
presented and,
uh, and so that alone
made this, like,
a visually
and, uh,
honestly, like,
a surprising entry
in the shooter
genre, where I think
the game falls flat
and why it
won't get my Essential Games
list vote is because I think
that the actual
assignment, right,
the actual, like, objectives
aren't all
that interesting,
uh, and it's just
kind of creating,
like, the, it's creating,
like, a workaround
for why they
couldn't just continue to make
destroying the enemy
bases and going
through the levels
more interesting
and so instead, the four enemy
bases all just wind up being
kind of the same
level again with more or less
enemies and different colored
graphics, but they didn't
change anything about that
and they disguised
that by giving you other little
objectives throughout
to be, like, okay,
that's how we'll break this up
rather than being, like,
no, the isometric part
is what we're going to commit to and we're
going to continue to subvert
expectations on,
like, what, how that functions,
you know, again, like, there would have
been a use to
the altitude to,
like, soar under
things or, like,
you know, almost, like,
navigating an
on-rails puzzle,
you know, in a sense,
like, these are the
kinds of things that I think
I was expecting once I started
to get familiar with the game
and once I realized what
it was actually offering,
it was just
kind of giving me little,
little time
wasters and
so the actual
game is
impressive and I think NES
fans should check it out,
but I don't
think it's enough to
recommend to a
general audience and so it
won't be on
my essential games list.
Sean? Yeah,
this was tough
because it was, like,
while I was playing it I
was definitely
debating, like, do I vote this
essential? Because it's
very, it's become
very rare for
me to have that thought
even cross my mind.
game. and it's sort
of the same thing for me.
I think that
this game has
a lot going
for it, but of what
it has going for it,
it, like, they're,
they're just, it just doesn't
happen very often.
Like, they're,
the game is
actually very short and
the moments
that, that were the
high points, and there,
there are those,
and when they are high,
they are high,
but they're just,
you'll blink
and you'll miss them.
Like, when you're
sort of in the isometric
areas, and you're
fighting against other jets
like you,
and it kind of feels like
a race, or like
something out of Spy
Hunter maybe, and you're
kind of jockeying for
position, and then
you're able to finally
down him, like, that felt
really good,
but it only happens like
three times in the entire
game. So,
like, yeah, the presentation's
great, a lot of the
stuff that you're doing is fun,
but it just,
it feels like
half of the
game is here.
So, if there was,
if they ever did make
Captain Skyhawk
2, I'd have high hopes that that
would be an
essential game, but alas,
it didn't happen. But this one
is just a
play it for me.
Next week, we'll be playing
Castle of Dragon,
not to be confused with the
hit game show
Castle or Dragon.
Castle or Dragon?
Yeah, you know, that hit game show
that you always catch on the game show network
at like 3 in the morning,
Castle or Dragon,
where the three
contestants have to guess whether the
thing behind the
curtain is a castle,
like, from Transylvania,
or a live
dragon. I don't think I
ever caught that one.
Huh. We must not be
watching the same game show network.
Yeah. Also keep in
mind that there are a lot of
other things Nostalgia has
to offer, so quick plug
in for our
Patreon, patreon.com
slash Nostalgia.
For just $1,
you get access to the
Discord. You can meet
a bunch of people who
might just be like you or
people that you can argue with
online. Just kidding.
We don't argue in the Discord.
Everybody just
tells us how wrong we
specifically are
on our Essential Games
list. So if you want to get in on that
fun, that's a
dollar. And then for $5,
you can get access to
Nostalgia Bites.
Which is our meal prep service
where we will send you the
ingredients of
the food and
you cook it at home.
It's always
farm fresh, always sourced
locally, and it'll
always be
sort of
tangy. I want all
of the food to have sort of
a tang to
it. And that's
what we do.
Yep. And all the
meals, come in
little boxes
shaped like castles and
are made of real live
dragons. All white
dragon meat. All white
stuff. Those
up stuff Those suck Those! Thank you.